Trascrizione: Mauro Costantino
Revisore: Michelangelo Bardella
Vi invito a viaggiare con me
nel mio passato
per raccontarvi un po’
il mio viaggio, la mia odissea.
La mia odissea nasce già
quand’ero in pancia a mia madre,
perché sono figlio di ragazza madre.
Nel 1969, quando sono nato,
era uno scandalo,
e mia madre è stata cacciata via di casa,
e quindi è andata raminga
per i fratelli e per chi poteva
accoglierla in casa,
quindi anch’io facevo
il mio viaggio insieme a mia madre.
Nasco in un periodo
all’inizio degli anni settanta
e quindi il boom demografico,
il boom economico.
Però vivo in un’epoca davvero triste,
perché la mia adolescenza
e la mia gioventù
la vivo negli anni terribili,
dall′87 al ’91,
dopo che sono entrato in marina,
inizio a farmi le canne.
Inizio a farmi le canne che è bellissimo,
però poi non mi bastavano.
Poi ho iniziato a fare gli acidi,
poi ho preso la cocaina,
e poi sono stato scoperto in marina
che ero un tossico
e quindi mi hanno mandato via,
e questo al posto di aiutarmi
a uscire fuori da una situazione
mi ha mandato giù ancora di più.
E quindi ho vissuto
un fallimento fortissimo,
fallimento lavorativo
perché guadagnavo bene in marina,
ero volontario
quindi prendevo bei soldi.
Un fallimento affettivo,
perché io ero un figlio
e il figlio che mai
nessuna mamma avrebbe voluto.
Ero rabbioso, ero una persona ribelle
e davo davvero tanto fastidio.
Quando sono uscito fuori dalla marina,
al posto di rinsavirmi
ho iniziato a farmi di eroina
e questo mi ha portato davvero
nei meandri della vita.
Io penso che la mia vita
sia una vita verso il basso.
Io non sono come Ulisse,
io non voglio ritornare.
Io voglio andare avanti,
io voglio andare sempre avanti
perché la vita è avanti, Dio è avanti.
Io ho fatto l’esperienza di Dio, è nuova,
grazie al fatto che, dopo che sono uscito
fuori dalla tossicodipendenza,
vi posso assicurare che uscire fuori dalla
tossicodipendenza è traumatico.
Ancora oggi il 90 per cento delle persone
che si drogano
non escono fuori dall’eroina,
entrano ed escono dalle comunità,
è difficilissimo, ti scarnifica.
Ti toglie qualsiasi dignità umana.
Io, quando sono uscito fuori
dalla tossicodipendenza,
grazie all’aiuto di mia madre
che mi è stata sempre vicina,
non mi ha mai abbandonato,
quando le ho chiesto aiuto era lì, anche
se io mia madre l’ho trattata malissimo.
Le ho alzato le mani.
Non la consideravo come mamma
perché l’eroina seda, seda gli affetti,
seda i sentimenti, seda le emozioni.
E allora, grazie a mia madre, quando sono
uscito fuori dalla tossicodipendenza,
io non volevo solo vivere.
Io volevo vivere di più.
Ancora di più.
Ancora più fortemente,
volevo che la mia vita fosse piena,
che potessi darmi a tutti
e che tutti potessero darsi a me.
E ho scoperto che la cosa più importante
nella vita sono le relazioni.
Sono le relazioni che ti danno gioia.
Sono le relazioni che ti dannano,
ma sono le relazioni
che ti danno la felicità piena.
E allora nella mia vita
ho iniziato a capire
che non potevo più vivere
solo per me stesso.
Non potevo più vivere solamente
per quello che mi piaceva,
ma quello che mi piaceva
poteva essere condiviso con gli altri.
E quello che piaceva agli altri
poteva piacere anche a me.
E allora ho iniziato a fare
un cammino di forte conversione,
e non una conversione verso Gesù.
Questa è venuta dopo,
ma una conversione verso l’umanità.
Io avevo sperimentato la mia disumanità.
E volevo diventare umano
perché noi nasciamo uomini,
ma possiamo fare
un cammino di disumanizzazione
o un cammino che ci porta all’umanità.
E paradossalmente Gesù
questo mi ha insegnato,
a diventare uomo, uomo vero.
Che non deve arrabattarsi per andare
a cercare chissà che cosa,
ma che può trovare ogni cosa nella vita.
È la vita la cosa bella,
è la vita che è bellezza,
è la vita che è la strada
dove vivo gli incontri.
È la vita che mi dà la possibilità
di esprimere me stesso,
e io credo nel dio della vita.
Ecco perché la vita mi appartiene.
Ecco perché la vita per me è importante,
non può essere più
barattata con qualcos’altro.
Io credo molto nel futuro.
Molto.
Ecco perché io non voglio
ritornare indietro
a Itaca come ha fatto Ulisse.
Io voglio andare avanti, voglio costruire
un futuro diverso per me
perché possa essere diverso
per tutti gli altri,
e io so che la mia diversità,
il mio modo di fare,
il mio modo di essere nella vita
può essere di stimolo solamente
quando non lo faccio per gli altri,
ma lo faccio per me.
Se voglio che il mondo cambi intorno
a me, il primo che deve cambiare sono io.
Io devo cambiare il mio sguardo, devo
cambiare il mio modo di vedere le cose
e di fare le cose, per dare alla vita
l’occasione di rispondermi
in una maniera diversa.
Noi alcune volte, almeno a me
è capitato nella mia vita,
di fare sempre le stesse cose
e di avere sempre le stesse risposte.
Il viaggio ci insegna
una cosa importantissima:
che possiamo cambiare.
“Eh, questo è il mio carattere”.
Quante volte l'ho detto.
Il viaggio mi ha raccontato
che non esiste un carattere
che ci può incasellare,
che ci può chiudere,
che ci può mettere
come un mosaico in una parte
e non farci muovere più, no.
Il carattere si può cambiare,
la vita, le relazioni si possono cambiare.
Se cambio io, cambia tutto quello
che sta intorno a me,
e questa è l’esperienza
che ho fatto di Dio,
un dio che non mi giudica,
un dio che non guarda
il passato che ho avuto,
il male che ho fatto,
ma il futuro che posso
costruire.
Non sono il mio passato, ma posso
essere il mio futuro.
San Paolo diceva: “Dimentico del passato,
corro verso il futuro”,
ed è il mio mantra.
Io voglio correre verso il futuro
e non ci voglio correre da solo.
Vorrei correre insieme a voi.
Questa città di Taranto,
che ha bisogno di guardare al futuro.
Non esiste solo l’Ilva.
Taranto e molto di più dell’Ilva,
come ognuno di voi è molto
di più di quanto può credere
e quanto può fare.
Questo è il mio viaggio.
Questo è quello che io voglio raccontarvi,
un viaggio che è iniziato dal basso.
Anzi no, è iniziato dall’alto,
è iniziato dall’alto del pensare solamente
a me stesso, dell’essere disumano,
ed è andato in basso.
Per essere davvero umano,
proprio come Gesù,
che da divino che era è diventato uomo
per dirci che ciascuno di noi
può essere un dio.
Ciascuno di noi è Dio quando ama l’altro.
Quando... sperimenta la bellezza
e la sa trasportare agli altri.
È Dio quando è solidale.
È Dio quando sa accogliere.
È Dio quando sa amare.
Grazie.
[Applausi]